Most traders take months, even years to
build the right foundation. But if you
focus for just the next three days, you
can build a better one than most traders
ever do. In this video, I'm going to lay
out exactly what you should do each day
from setting up your platform to
building a trading plan and actually
executing your first trade. So then you
can avoid the key mistakes that cost me
years and thousands of dollars. And at
the end, I'll show you the exact
strategy that I use every single morning
that generated over $5,000 in the last
30 days, even though I lost half the
trades I took. It took me over 5 years
to figure the strategy out. And this is
what I wish I knew when I first started
trading. Okay, so day one, actually
today, do this today, is start looking
at a ton of videos about chart analysis
and reading candlesticks. You want to
really start to understand with the goal
of mastering how to just read what a
chart of any market is telling you. You
do not want to be looking for an
indicator combo that is going to tell
you where to buy and where to sell
because those just don't exist. If that
was actually a thing, everyone would
make money easily trading. At the end of
the day, trading's hard. And what those
indicators do is they can help you make
an educated decision. But at the end of
the day, everyone who is using them
profitably understands the raw data of
what just reading candlesticks and chart
patterns tells you. And then as you're
doing that, set up a trading platform so
you can look at charts as you're
watching these videos. I recommend using
Ninja Trader for your trading platform.
It's what I've used for the past 5
years. It's extremely fast for its trade
entries and its ability for
customization. I'll leave a link for
that in the description below this video
or you can check it out via this QR
code. Now, later we'll go into a couple
more important tools that you're going
to want to access when you're actually
executing trades and looking at scaling
your account. But before we get into
that, let's jump into day two. Day two
is going to be massive in terms of the
amount of leg work you're going to do
building this foundation. First off,
continue watching videos, but now start
watching videos on actual strategies and
narrowing your focus down to a strategy
you like. Something that could get you
stuck losing at trading for the next 5
years like I did is if one you jump into
a trade alert service right away. A lot
of people think these are going to make
the money, make it a lot easier to learn
a trade, but a lot of time is it's
actually almost impossible to make money
consistently following those and you're
not learning how to trade yourself. Hold
off on joining something like that for a
while. And probably the biggest trap
traders fall into and the one that
really stuck me losing money for 5 years
is jumping from strategy to strategy.
There are infinite ways to trade the
market because there's infinite time
frames. There's infinite patterns.
There's just infinite rules that you can
follow because trading just has so many
options and you can do whatever you
want. You can always enter or exit in
whenever you want. And so out there on
the internet, there's so many different
strategies that you can do. But what you
can get stuck in is this kind of
dopamine trap of when you learn a new
strategy, you're excited about this is
going to be the strategy that I can make
money with. You try it, it doesn't
really work right away for a couple
reasons, and then you jump to the next
strategy and you get another dopamine
hit of excitement that you're going to
try the strategy out. And this is the
cycle that repeats over and over. We'll
talk about a couple reasons in a minute
of how to make sure you can get out of
that learning loop and find an actual
strategy that works for you. Now, once
you have found that strategy and a rough
idea of how you want to trade, create an
actual plan that you're going to follow.
Trading is massive when it comes to
following a plan. If you don't follow
something that you're trying to
consistently do, it's impossible to know
if it's repeatable. If you're trying to
just throw paint at the wall and see
what sticks in terms of what makes money
and what doesn't, it's going to be
impossible to know how to repeat it
consistently over time. And so there's
four key things to think about when
you're making a plan. Number one is what
is your actual setup? Are you looking
for reversals, continuation trades when
two indicators align and you know this
certain pattern shows up? And then
second is why are you entering? For me,
I have a pretty standard 3 to fivestep
checklist that I follow every single
trade. I look for reversals. I want to
see a key support or resistance level. I
want to see a trend break into that
level that shows me that the trend could
actually slow down and reverse. And then
after that, I want to see a clean double
bottom or reversal candlestick pattern.
And then generally a really strong
candlestick that shows there's good
momentum in the direction that I want.
And following that every time allows me
to know that this is something that I
can consistently repeat because I'm
following the same structure every time.
And then the third thing is how do you
actually enter? Are you entering in with
a stop-loss, a limit order? What kind of
order are you using essentially? Are you
entering in on a one minute chart, a
five minute chart, an hour chart? And
then once you actually enter, how do you
actually manage your trade? You want to
figure out what that is before you jump
into the trade because once you're in
the trade, all bets are off. You are
going to get emotional and if you don't
have a plan to follow, you're not going
to make a good decision. You want to
think about where is my stop loss going
to go when I enter the trade? Where is
my profit target going to be? Am I going
to kind of fluidly manage it or I'm
going to have a fixed profit target
where I'm just going for a set spot that
the market I think is going to hit and
then I get out and I move on with my
day. As you're first starting out, I
highly recommend keeping it super
simple, like a 1:2 riskreward ratio
where let's say for an example, you risk
$100 every trade and then your profit
target is set to be two times that. So
you'd be going for $200. This will allow
you to really focus on your entries.
Don't get bogged down in trying a fancy
management style where you are scaling
in, scaling out, having, you know,
trailing stop losses. That's really
complicated. And 90% of what trading is
is having the correct entry. If you
enter in in the right spot, you're going
to make money no matter how you manage
it. Sure, managing is going to allow you
to make, you know, maybe 5 or 10% more
from your best trades, but at that
point, you're just trying to minmax, and
that's not what you want to be focused
on when you start out. Save that for
down the road. Then, the last thing for
day two is figure out your actual daily
trading routine based on your life and
your schedule. What makes sense for when
you are going to trade throughout your
day? Are you going to just check in
throughout the day? Are you going to
trade just 60 minutes in the morning and
then be done with the day? The key of
why this is important is it'll allow you
to structure things to where you go in,
focus on trading, and then once that
time is up, you're done. You don't want
to just perpetually have a random plan
of just trying to show up and and trade
for as long as you want because trading
is all about making the correct
decision. And if you trade too long or
you're frustrated because trading's been
a struggle and you know, let's say took
a loss on the day and you stay longer,
you're more likely to produce more
losses because you are tired and not
able to make a good decision. Correct
decisions in trading make money. And so
only trade when you can make a correct
decision. And a big thing that really
was frustrating for me in the beginning
and I think plagues all traders when
they first started out is thinking that
any strategy is going to produce good
trades all the time. No matter what time
frame you're trading, all strategies
will have es and flows in the number of
trades you take because the market has
es and flows. Sometimes the market's
really hot and there's a ton of really
good trade setups and you have to just
be laser focused and you're taking
trades left and right and it's crazy and
it's really exciting. And other times
the market is just flat, it's boring for
days on end and it feels like you're
never going to make a good trade again
and you you feel like you need to take a
trade because otherwise you're just
sitting there wasting your time. And in
reality, you're sitting there waiting
for your profitable strategy to show up.
Most of the time, anyone trying to trade
can make money when the market is good
and it fits their strategy. When they're
losing money is when the market slows
down and they're not able to realize
that and shift gears and they end up
overtrading, taking bad trades, and
losing a lot of money. Don't have a
daily trading goal of either number of
trades or certain profit for a day
because you don't know when the market's
going to be really good or really bad.
You want to just kind of be a blank
slate of flexibility and wait for the
market to fit your plan. And if it does,
you take a trade. And if it doesn't, you
just move on with the day. Now, before
we move on to day three, I want to show
you my 90day trader roadmap. This is
going to just go more in depth into kind
of what your progress should really look
like over the next 90 days of trading.
These first 3 days are going to be
really accelerated and really massive
for your foundation. But I highly
recommend getting this 90-day trader
road map that you will either get via
this QR code or the link in the
description of this video. It will have
way more tools, links to everything
we've talked about and guide you kind of
on the direction you want for trading.
Now, so day three, by this point, you
have your plan, a strategy, a kind of
foundation built of roughly how you want
to do things going forwards. This is
when you're going to start executing
your strategy. But first, start doing it
on a demo account. I have got emails and
messages from people saying they've lost
thousands, tens of thousands in some
cases because they're too eager to jump
into what they've learned. Getting into
trading is super exciting because it's
such an interesting space and the
ability to make a lot of money is real,
but the ability to lose money right away
is way more likely as a beginner.
Mistakes in trading lose you money and
you're going to make a ton of mistakes
when you first start out. So, be
patient. Give yourself a little bit of
time. You don't need to jump into it
right away with real money and
especially a lot of money. Start with a
demo account. Just practice trading on a
charting system like Ninja Trader. And
we'll talk about scaling up in a second.
But start following your routine and
following your plan that you've laid
out. And this is where the biggest thing
of breaking that learning loop comes
into play. The whole idea here is you
need to for the foreseeable future is
stick to this strategy. Stick to it for
10 to 20 trades and slowly refine it and
master it. Don't go and try and find
another indicator to add to your
strategy or different pattern to use.
Those are going to start you over from
square one. For me, my strategy, what
worked was finding one system and one
really simple style that I could master
and spend, you know, your 10,000 hours
finding and figuring out every little
detail about. I don't add or combine new
things constantly trying to make it
better when it doesn't work out. That is
what's going to keep you out of the
learning loop of jumping to a different
strategy is realizing that just because
it's not working. It's not necessarily
because of the strategy. Think about why
you didn't jump into a trade when your
strategy said you should have or maybe
you chased a trade that you actually
shouldn't have been in because the
strategy didn't say you were supposed to
be in. Start journaling and tracking the
trades you take and even some of the
trades you miss that your strategy says
you should have gotten in. It will be
very enlightening into what is actually
negatively impacting you from
successfully executing a trading
strategy. And ideally you can you know
make little tweaks, take things away, do
what makes sense in terms of refining
the strategy but don't do massive
changes. That is what's going to set you
back. And when it comes to it, try and
become consistently profitable on a demo
account for 1 to two months, depending
on the time frame you're trading. What
this will do is it'll help you kind of
get through that initial phase of
trading. And then what I highly
recommend you do is switch over to a
brokerage account and put in let's say
$500. It does not have to be a large
amount of money. The idea here is you
are now practicing your strategy with
real money. It's going to start to
become more real. It's going to be more
nerve-wracking. More greed is going to
come in. A lot of your emotions are
going to come in and start trying to
mess you up when real money is involved
versus demo trading. And so, if you
start out with a really small amount,
it's going to make that stress and
intensity less for you. And then you can
start to again continue honing and
getting better at trading at slow
increments. You don't want to be trying
to make a massive jump to trading a
$10,000 account. Even if you have that
kind of money to trade and test out with
trading, it's all about getting 1%
better every single day. And then from
there, you can either slowly scale up
your brokerage account or if you want
to, you can start a funded account
challenge, which will allow you to pay
some money and pass a couple tests to
gain access to, let's say, a $50,000
account. And this is a really nice way
to get capital when you don't have it or
just don't want to risk it, frankly. But
I highly recommend don't do this when
you first start out because there's a
lot of fees involved if you are not
consistent with trading and you're
essentially paying a lot of fees to demo
trade. But you're going to potentially
lose more money just paying the fees of
these platforms than just trying with
your own real money of let's say $500.
And so you want to have kind of a rough
idea of you know what you're doing.
You've shown a little bit of a track
record before you do that. And then you
can start to scale up and increase the
amount of money you can make trading.
Now, in the last 30 days, I only took 10
trades and I actually made $5,000 even
with a 50% win rate. Only half of those
trades won. But it's because I was
following a simple strategy that I've
created and honed over years. This
strategy has actually made other traders
who have tried it successful at trading
with the same strategy. And so I highly
recommend checking out this video right
here. It'll walk you through that whole
strategy that I use and one that you can
start to work on yourself over these
next three days.